hi wack 'it is directed by adam mcdonald
the director of backcountry a film that
premiered at tiff in 2014 this film is
also premiering at if this year and
tells the story of leah a young girl
played by nicole munos who's dealing
with a family tragedy her mother played
by Laurie Holden uproots them and takes
them to a new house in the middle of the
woods
to escape from her depression and her
anxiety she has delved deep into the
occult and because of this in a moment
of terrible rage her mom says something
awful to her and she decides you know
what I'm gonna try to conjure something
to take care of my mother and when it
actually happens she regrets every
decision she made and now she has to
deal with some unseen entity that's
terrorizing her and her mother
I thought McDonald's last film
backcountry was fairly underappreciated
he has a very good knack for taking
limited resources and a very small
budget and using it to the best of his
ability by creating characters and
situations that bring forth tension not
just the horror elements of the film in
backcountry it was a bear in this film
it's this witch that is conjured because
of this decision that Leah's character
makes rather than often relying on overt
scare horror tactics which are in this
film and if you are a horrible
especially an indie horror buff you're
going to get that this film relies on
tension built through the
mother-daughter relationship that's
crumbling to the ground if you were to
take all of the horror elements out of
Pi wagget you would still have a fairly
compelling drama about a mother and a
daughter dealing with a tragedy which is
one of the reasons why the film worked
for me the characters are well fleshed
out the characters are set up in
compelling ways that makes you actually
care when things start to go down the
horror path he also has a really great
way of taking what is normally used as a
moment to heighten the tension by
setting up some great scare like you pan
up something's a leg and then oh my god
there it is or the music lets you know
that something really horrible is about
to happen rather than doing that
McDonald often just cuts to something
and presents it to you in a wide shot
and says here's
look at it sometimes the scariest
elements of film are things that appear
in the background of shots things that
maybe you don't notice at first
or perhaps are on the screen for a long
period of time before your eye looks
over to the corner and realizes that
there's something terrifying in the
image that happens during Pi Waggett
about 30 minutes through there's a wide
shot of a forest and our main character
Leah is standing in the foreground but
if you look in the background you can
tell that there is something standing
behind a tree and when I noticed that it
just unsettled me and it gave me goose
bumps across my entire body this movie
uses minimal effects on a limited amount
of resources to build tension through
sound design performances and effective
camerawork McDonald utilizes handheld
shots to intensify the atmosphere and
where normally this guerilla style
filmmaking can sometimes cheapen the
look of a film here it created a
fly-on-the-wall type feeling where you
felt like you were observing characters
going through something horrific rather
than being told every single beat
through horror moments and musical cues
that were used to experiencing there's a
sense of voyeurism also because
oftentimes he will have long Steadicam
shots of the point of view of pie wagon
or maybe he used a ronin I don't know
and he's going through the woods and
trees are passing and you realize that
you are seeing whatever the witch is
seeing at this point and that
voyeuristic take on it also made me feel
unsettled there's one particular shot
where the camera hovers over someone's
sleeping and I just kept imagining what
it would be like if I opened my eyes and
saw whatever this thing looks like which
is something else I liked about pie
wagget is that he often keeps this thing
hidden you don't really see it too often
which brings me into one of my flaws
when you do see pie Waggett it sometimes
does drain the tension because this is a
very low-budget film there's a great
wide shot towards the very end of the
movie that was very very creepy but
there's a sequence in the middle where
it kind of appears as this form that I
felt drained the tension from the moment
and the effect wasn't as strong as it
should have been there's also a scene
about halfway through in the woods with
two characters that I thought was really
effective and it was actually really
starting to creep me out it gave me a
very
which type feel but then it ends up
being a joke and I was like come on like
that to me that was just a little bit of
a cop-out I also felt the ending was a
bit rushed while I was able to make
sense of what occurs it felt like we
needed an extra 10 minutes with the
characters to breathe about what happens
but at the same time it's also really
important to end a horror film at the
height of drama at the height of fear at
that big moment and not really
necessarily give you that release that
some other films do similar to what
Blair Witch did it just cuts out and
you're like okay who let me take a
breath and kind of think about what just
happens so I can also praised the film
for having an ending like that but it
just felt like I could have used maybe
five or ten more minutes of character
scenes but I feel like maybe on second
viewing that won't be an issue so much
now that I was able to really think
about what occurs in the film because
it's the type of ending and of course I
won't give it away that is a little
ambiguous all of the pieces of the
puzzle are there you just have to think
about it and put it together the film
doesn't present you a completed puzzle
on a platter and says here feel good
about this ending it forces you to think
about it and asks you to figure out how
certain events could have happened with
limited knowledge of what happens it
puts you in Leah's shoes and makes you
try to figure out how these things
occurred for some people that might be
really maddening but I like when films
force you to think especially an indie
horror film and I have a lot of respect
for indie horror filmmakers because I
know what it's like to try to make a
movie with very limited resources and a
very small budget and oftentimes horror
filmmakers because I've seen it they try
to just have a bunch of blood or a bunch
of you know girls running around
half-naked or other things that they
think they have to put in their film to
make up for the lack of a budget Adam
McDonald clearly doesn't feel that way
he chooses to rely on character moments
things that don't cost a lot of money to
film to boost the strength of the horror
elements and that's something that
McDonald has done really well here the
overall theme of the film seems to be
that you are your own worst enemy
sometimes what we think we need in life
and how we struggle to obtain it
ultimately becomes our downfall and I
like that this tiny indie horror film
has a hidden meaning like that
it makes you ask questions it makes you
think about what would you do in this
situation and it gives us compelling
lead characters Laurie Holden is really
good as the mother and Nicole Munoz is
also excellent without their good
performances and some of the smaller
scenes between the two the horror
wouldn't work as well yes at times it
does feel like a very small movie
without a big budget and sometimes a
maybe a few extra thousand dollars would
have helped with a few of the effects
but I appreciated the restraint this is
a very uncommon trait in horror
filmmakers restraint when you have
things at your disposal sometimes you
really want to show it you really you
really want to utilize it but the best
horror films don't I'm gonna give it a
B+ so I hear that a viewer of mine named
Jack fern had his 24th birthday
yesterday happy birthday buddy I also
hear that he is in the path of hurricane
Emma I really hope you're safe and that
you're staying secure and that
everything works out for you buddy
thanks for watching guys thank you so
much as always and if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes
[Music]